l'actualité nous le rappelle trop
souvent et encore ce weekend nous
assistons à une hausse des violences lié
à ces trafic de
stupéfiant on voit bien que c'est pour
ces organisations criminelles qui
contrôlent ces trafics un moyen d'assoir
leur remprise ou de l'augmenter en
essayant de de récupérer des marchés qui
pourraient être contrôlés par des équipe
rivale c'est aussi une méthode de
représail qui mal heureusement
s'installe dans des logiques devant
d'État dont on ne voit jamais la fin
entre groupes entre groupes rivaux ça se
manifeste à la fois par des opérations
d'enlèvement de séquestration de torture
et des homicides tentatives d'homicide
volontaire dont on peut malheureusement
constater qu'elles s'étendent au-delà
des villes qui les constaté
régulièrement de manière assez striite à
assez triste des villes des villes
moyennes de taille moyenne un peu
partout sur le territoire national j'ai
décidé de pas vous parler de vous donner
beaucoup de chiffres mais en ce qui
concerne ce phénomène je pense qu'il est
important d'être assez clair pour
montrer le niveau de gravité
exceptionnel de ce qui se passe au 13
novembre 2023 nous avons constaté 35
homicide ou tentative d'homicide entre
malfaiteurs ce qui correspond à une
augmentation de 57 % par rapport à la
même période en
2022 parmi les 451 victimes recensées
puisque it peut provoquer plusieurs
malheureusement plusieurs victimes 30 %
on moins de 20
ans et on voit bien que dans certaines
villes je l'ai dit que ça soit à
Marseille à Nice à nî ces phénomènes là
aussi s'étendre au-delà de la périphérie
des villes dans les centres-villes dans
des logiques devant d'État comme je
l'indiquais cette diminution de l'âge
des victimes se retrouve aussi chez les
auteurs on assiste quand ils sont
interpellés
à un âge malheureusement très faible de
ceux qui qui se livre à ces actes qui
sont sans doute la conséquence d'une
balinisation à la fois de l'accès aux
armes à feu et de l'usage qui peut qui
peut en être faite qui peut en être fait
malheureusement là aussi on a pu le
constater au cours de weekend avec des
victimes collatéral comme ça s'est passé
donc à Dijon comme ça a pu se passer à
nî ou comme ça a pu se passer à à
Marseille